NEW YORK TO TAKE OVER.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
I WILL ACCEPT THE INTRO, BUT I
DO NOT DESERVE IT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE WILL BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
MULTIPLE NEWS BREAKING STORIES
TONIGHT.
AN URGENT SITUATION IN MULTIPLE
CITIES, CHAOS, DEADLY VIOLENCE
IN SEATTLE’S SO-CALLED
AUTONOMOUS CHOP, CHAS, SUMMER OF
FREE LOVE ZONE.
WE WILL TAKE YOU THERE IN A
MOMENT.
AND CHAOS IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
TONIGHT, DEMONSTRATORS
ATTEMPTING TO CREATE THEIR OWN
AUTONOMOUS ZONE RIGHT THERE IN
OUR NATION’S CAPITAL OUTSIDE OF
THE WHITE HOUSE.
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR OPENING
MONOLOGUE, LET’S GO LIVE TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHERE
FOX NEWS’ KEVIN CORKE IS
STANDING BY WITH A LIVE REPORT.
APPARENTLY LOST -- KEVIN IS
THERE.
TELL US WHAT YOU GOT.
OKAY, WE DON’T HAVE KEVIN.
WE HAD HIM, WE DON’T HAVE THEM.
WE DO HAVE OTHER BREAKING NEWS,
BACK TO THAT IN THE MOMENT THERE
THAT WAS EARLIER TONIGHT.
WE’VE ALSO TAKEN ON THE GROUND
TO SEATTLE FOR A LIVE REPORT.
WE WILL BRING YOU BREAKING NEWS
THERE IS HAPPENING EVERYWHERE.
ALSO THE SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO WILL JOIN US TONIGHT
ON TOP OF ALL OF THIS
BREAKING NEWS.
VIOLENCE HAS BEEN NOW ERUPTING
IN AMERICA’S MAJOR CITIES ALL
WEEKEND LONG.
IT IS BAD.
IF SHOOTINGS ROBBERIES, SALT.
THIS WEEKEND WE SAW CARNAGE ON
AN ABSOLUTELY SHOCKING AND
UNACCEPTABLE LEVEL.
WE WANT TO BE A COUNTRY, A
UNITED STATES.
THE FIRST THING WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH HIS SAFETY AND
SECURITY.
BOTTOM LINE.
NEXT THING WE MIGHT WANT TO DO
IS FIX THESE BROKEN SCHOOLS.
YOU ARE WATCHING A RAPID
DETERIORATION AND DISINTEGRATION
OF OUR MAJOR CITIES.
DEMOCRATIC MAYORS AND GOVERNORS
WHO HAVE BEEN IN CHARGE FOR
DECADES ARE NOW CLUELESS,
UNABLE, UNWILLING TO FIX IT.
THESE ARE OUR FELLOW AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THEY HAVE FAILED THEIR
CONSTITUENTS HERE IN, YEAR OUT,
NOW AMERICANS ARE SUFFERING.
WE ARE WATCHING THIS FAR LEFT
RADICAL AGENDA PLAY OUT IN REAL
TIME AND FRANKLY, IT IS A SAD --
IT IS A SCARY PICTURE AND WE’RE
GOING TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
AMERICA’S LIBERAL CITIES IN
CRISIS BECAUSE IN 134 DAYS, YOU
WILL BE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
WHAT IS NOW BECOMING VISIBLE FOR
ALL TO SEE AND ALL THESE LIBERAL
CITIES AND HIS LIBERAL STATES,
WELL, IF THEY WIN IN NOVEMBER
AND 134 DAYS AND IMPLEMENT THEIR
NEW GREENFIELD IN THEIR RADICAL
LEFTIST AGENDA, YOU CAN PRETTY
MUCH ASSUME THE SAME RESULTS.
IF WE START WITH THE NEWS IN
SEATTLE AS WE’VE BEEN REPORTING.
THE DEMOCRATS THERE HAVE RULED
THAT CITY FOR THREE DECADES.
EIGHT STRAIGHT DEMOCRATS HAVE
SERVED AS MAYOR.
IT’S A ONE-PARTY TOWN.
CRIME IS SPIRALING OUT OF
CONTROL.
VIOLENT CRIME IS UP BY 30% THE
PAST THREE YEARS.
IN FEBRUARY THE DOWNTOWN SEATTLE
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OPENLY
WORRIED THAT THE CITY "COULD BE
RUINED BY DRUGS, RANDOM ATTACKS,
SHOOTINGS, AND HOMELESSNESS,"
BUT THAT DIDN’T STOP THE
DEMOCRATIC MAYOR OF SEATTLE,
JENNY DURKAN FROM, WELL,
SEATING, WHAT, SIX CITY BLOCKS.
THE MAIN PART OF SEATTLE TOO
LITERALLY A COLLECTION OF
ANARCHISTS, RADICALS, SOCIALISTS
AND OTHER SO-CALLED PROTESTERS.
SHE LET THEM TAKE OVER PARTS OF
AN ENTIRE CITY, INCLUDING A
POLICE PRECINCT.
WE SAW THEM BURN DOWN IN
NEW YORK AND OTHER CITIES AND
LITERALLY ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WERE KICKED OUT.
SHE ALLOWED THEM TO WALL OFF AN
ENTIRE AREA -- BASICALLY
COMMANDEER IT, TAKE IT OVER AND
PREVENT STORES FROM CONDUCTING
THEIR BUSINESS OF PROTECTING
AMERICAN BUSINESS OWNERS.
AND WORKERS.
SHE LET THEM LITERALLY LIGHT
FIRES BREAKING INTO THE
BUILDINGS AND SPRAY PAINT NEARLY
EVERY SURFACE WITH GRAFFITI.
SHE SAID, HOW LONG IS THIS GOING
TO GO ON?
SHE SAID IT MIGHT BE A WHOLE
SUMMER OF LOVE.
WITH A LOT OF POT LUCK SPAGHETTI
DINNERS, RIGHT, MAYOR?
THIS IS WHAT YOU SAID, RIGHT?
>> HOW LONG TO THINK SEATTLE AND
THOSE FEW BLOCKS LOOK LIKE THIS?
>> I DON’T KNOW, WE CAN HAVE A
SUMMER OF LOVE.
>> TELL THAT TO THE POLICE WHO
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN THAT
PRECINCT.
>> Sean: MULTIPLE MEDIA
OUTLETS ALSO REFERRING TO THIS
LAWLESS AREA AS A FESTIVE ZONE,
EVEN AS THE ANARCHISTS
THEMSELVES, WELL, TELLING THE
MEDIA, FAKE NEW CNN, MSDN C,
WHILE THEY ARE ALIVE AND THEY
ARE, THIS IS NOT A FESTIVE ZONE,
THEY STILL REPORTED AS A FESTIVE
ZONE.
DIDN’T LOOK TO FESTIVAL --
FESTIVE OVER THE WEEKEND.
IF MULTIPLE PEOPLE SHOT IN THE
SO-CALLED FESTIVE ZONE.
WE TOLD YOU ON THIS SHOW THIS IS
NOT GOING TO END WELL.
WE HAVE BEEN WARNING ALL.
WE MUST PROTECT EVERY AMERICAN.
WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE
"LAW & ORDER."
WE GOT TO STOP THE ASSAULT ON
POLICE.
WE ARE HEADED NOW TOWARDS 900
INJURED POLICE OFFICERS WITH
ROCKS AND BRICKS AND BOTTLES AND
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS AND SOME HAVE
DIED.
AND ON TOP OF SOME DYING WE HAVE
THE GUY IN VEGAS, COP SHOT AND
IS NOT PARALYZED FROM THE NECK
DOWN FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE.
AND THEN OTHER, THE LOOTING, THE
ARSON.
IT’S GOT TO STOP.
THE MEDIA ALSO NEEDS TO STOP
LYING AND SAYING IT’S A FESTIVE
ZONE WHEN IT’S NOT A FESTIVE
ZONE.
THERE WERE PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS -- EVERYONE WAS
UNANIMOUS ON THE GEORGE FLOYD
CASE.
THERE WAS VERY LITTLE
DISAGREEMENT.
IF THAT CAN’T IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN ONE INSTANCE WE HAD POLICE
DESPERATELY TRYING TO GET TO THE
SCENE OF THE SHOOTING IN THE
FESTIVE ZONE.
AUTONOMOUS ZONE, BUT THEY WERE
BLOCKED IN SEATTLE BY ANGRY
INDIVIDUALS.
WATCH THIS.
>> PLEASE MOVE OUT OF THE WAY SO
WE CAN GET TO THE VICTIM.
ALL WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS GET
TO THE VICTIM.
PLEASE ALLOW US TO GET BY INTO
THE AREA.
>> Sean: MAYOR, WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOUR SUMMER OF LOVE?
WHERE ARE YOU?
WHERE IS GOVERNOR INSLEE?
THIS IS YOUR STATE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN BEGGING
BOTH OF YOU TO ACCEPT HIS HELP.
JUST LIKE COMRADE de BLASIO,
GOVERNOR CUOMO OFFERED HELP
AGAIN AND AGAIN, JUST LIKE
CHICAGO, JUST LIKE ILLINOIS.
PRESIDENT OFFERING HELP TO
EVERYBODY.
WE DON’T WANT ANY HELP, WE CAN
HANDLE THIS.
IT DIDN’T WORK OUT TOO WELL AND
THAT PREDICTABLE.
THE MAYOR FINALLY TONIGHT, JUST
BREAKING, ALL OF A SUDDEN WANTS
TO WIND DOWN THE SUMMER OF LOVE
IN THE CHOP ZONE, THE CHAZ ZONE.
REALLY, NO MORE SUMMER OF LOVE,
MAYOR?
ALL TOLD, ONE PERSON KILLED, TWO
OTHERS GRAVELY INJURED DURING
THIS WEEKEND’S VIOLENCE IN THE
SO-CALLED, WELL, CAPITOL HILL
OCCUPY PROTEST OR CHOP, AS ONE
BUSINESS OWNER PUT IT, "CHOP
DESTROYED THE NEIGHBORHOOD, MADE
EVERYONE THERE FEEL UNSAFE" AND
AS YOU CAN SEE, MAYOR DURKAN,
WELL, YOU’RE WIND DOWN IS A
LITTLE TOO LITTLE, TOO LATE AND
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THE SAME
THING IN NEARLY EVERY MAJOR
LIBERAL CITY.
WE MUST, FOR THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF ALL AMERICANS,
RESTORE LAW AND RESTORE ORDER.
NOW THESE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS
AND MAYORS HAVE REFUSED TO DO
SO.
LET’S GO TO CHICAGO AS AN
EXAMPLE.
THAT’S BEEN RULED BY DEMOCRATS
NOW AND MAYORS, DEMOCRATIC
MAYORS SINCE 1933.
WANT TO KNOW WHY IT’S A MESS?
THERE YOU GO.
THE CITY’S GOVERNMENT SOFT ON
CRIME APPROACH HAS LED TO A
SEEMINGLY NEVER-ENDING WAVE OF
VIOLENCE.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THIS PAST
WEEKEND 104 OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
WERE SHOT, INCLUDING 12
CHILDREN.
14 PEOPLE DIED THIS WEEKEND.
IT’S KIND OF LIKE, WELL, JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOVE AVERAGE IN
CHICAGO.
THEY DO NOTHING TO SAVE THAT
CITY AND THE PEOPLE KEEP THEM
SAFE AND SECURE EVEN IN THEIR
OWN HOMES.
NEVER MIND THAT THE DILAPIDATED
BROKEN DOWN CORRUPT SCHOOL
SYSTEM WHERE KIDS DON’T MIND
READING, WRITING AND MATH.
IN NEW YORK CITY, COMRADE
DE BLASIO, WELL, TWO TERMS IN
OFFICE, WELL, GUESS WHAT, HE
WRECKED A ONCE PEACEFUL CITY
THAT HE INHERITED.
HIS ANTIPOLICE, SOFT ON CRIME
POLICIES ALONG WITH CUOMO’S GET
OUT OF JAIL FREE, NO JAIL REFORM
IS DESTROYING NOT ONLY
NEW YORK CITY, BUT
NEW YORK STATE.
AND THEY STAND BY THEIR
STUPIDITY.
JUST LIKE THEY WERE AWFUL ON
CORONAVIRUS.
LOOK AT NEW YORK CITY, SHOOTINGS
UP A WHOPPING 358% OVER LAST
YEAR.
JUST THIS WEEKEND NEW YORK CITY,
28 SEPARATE SHOOTINGS, 38
VICTIMS.
DO KNOW THE NAMES OF ANY OF OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS IN CHICAGO,
SEATTLE, NEW YORK, DID YOU KNOW
THE NAMES OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
SHOT, THOSE KIDS THAT WERE SHOT,
THOSE PEOPLE THAT DIED?
KNOW, THE MEDIA BARELY REPORTS
IT BURIED MINNEAPOLIS WHERE A
DEMOCRAT HAS BEEN MAYOR SINCE
1978, ALSO VIOLENCE SPIRALING
OUT OF CONTROL.
AT LEAST THEY’RE THE PRESIDENT
DID GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO IN
AND HELP STOP THE VIOLENCE IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, SERIOUS
CRIMES WERE UP BY 70%.
OF COURSE NOW AFTER THE
CITY COUNCIL NOW VOWED TO
DISMANTLE THE ENTIRE POLICE
DEPARTMENT, GUESS WHAT, SEVEN
POLICE OFFICERS HAVE ANNOUNCED
THEIR RESIGNATION.
VIOLENT CRIME HAS ENSUED.
IN JUST ONE SHOOTING OVER THE
WEEKEND, 11 PEOPLE WERE INJURED
THERE, ONE DAD THERE.
AGAIN, OUR FELLOW AMERICANS.
THIS ISN’T JUST A FAILURE OF
LEADERSHIP ON THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL.
NATIONALLY, TOP DEMOCRATS, THEY
HAVE TURNED A BLIND EYE TO
VIOLENT CRIME FOR DECADES.
JOE BIDEN, OKAY, JOE, YOU’RE
GOING TO LECTURE EVERYBODY IN
TERRY McAULIFFE, I’M FINE WITH
JOE IN THE BASEMENT.
TWO PEOPLE A DAY, TWO PEOPLE,
THAT’S ALL HE SEES.
I’M FINE, LEAVE HIM THERE.
HE’S BEEN IN POLITICS 51 YEARS,
JOE, WHAT DID YOU DO AFTER
FERGUSON?
WHAT DID YOU DO AFTER BALTIMORE?
WHAT DID YOU DO AFTER CAMBRIDGE?
NOTHING.
SPEAKER PELOSI, SHE’S BEEN IN
POLITICS 44 YEARS.
SENIOR SENATOR FROM CALIFORNIA
DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAS BEEN, WELL,
A PUBLIC OFFICE NOW FOR OVER
THREE DECADES.
MAXINE WATERS HAS HELD OFFICE
SINCE 1976.
PATRICK LAHEY, HE’S BEEN IN THE
U.S. SENATE A WHOPPING 45 YEARS.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE?
THESE DEMOCRATS ALL CLAIM TO
CARE ABOUT AMERICA’S
INTER-CITIES.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE DECADE AFTER
DECADE AFTER DECADE?
EVERY TWO YEARS, EVERY FOUR
YEARS, WHAT DO WE HEAR,
CONSERVATIVES, RACIST,
HOMOPHOBIC, XENOPHOBIC,
ISLAMOPHOBIC, THEY WANT DIRTIER
WATER AND THEY WANT TO KILL
CHILDREN AND WANT TO THROW
GRANDMA AND GRANDPA OVER A
CLIFF.
IT’S THE SAME PLAYBOOK BY THE
DEMOCRATS EVERY 214 YEARS.
IT’S NOT TRUE BECAUSE NOT ALL
TRUMP’S LEADERSHIP, RECORD AFTER
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH ON EMPLOYMENT
AND AFRICAN-AMERICAN YOUTH ON
EMPLOYMENT.
IT DIDN’T HAPPEN UNDER BARACK
AND JOE WHEN THEY HAD EIGHT
YEARS.
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS, 8 MILLION MORE ON
POVERTY IN THE LOWEST LABOR
PARTICIPATION RATE SINCE THEY
FOSTER A 70s.
THEY’VE BEEN MORE FOCUSED ON
EXPANDING POWER IN THE OF
GOVERNMENT OVER FREEDOM AND THE
LIVES OF LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS
WHO ARE NOT BEING PROTECTED IN
OUR CITIES.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND MOMS AND
DADS AND GRANDMAS AND GRANDPA’S
WHILE THEY’VE BEEN CODDLING
CRIMINALS IN THESE BIG CITIES,
LETTING CRIMINALS OUT, SANCTUARY
CITIES, SANCTUARY STATES AND
WREAKING HAVOC ON AMERICA’S
STREETS.
IF YOU WANT TO LIVE FREE, UNIT
LAW AND YOU NEED ORDER AND YOU
NEED SAFETY AND YOU NEED
SECURITY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT’S THE SIMPLE HANNITY ROLL.
I THINK ALL AMERICANS CAN AGREE
ON.
IN THE NEXT THING, LET’S FIX
AMERICA’S BROKEN, DILAPIDATED --
FRANKLY WHAT IS A DESPICABLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY WE SPEND MORE
PER CAPITA THAN ANY OTHER
INDUSTRIALIZED NATION ON
EDUCATION WITH THE WORST
RESULTS.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
HOW WAS IT POSSIBLE IN THE CITY
OF BALTIMORE, THIRD HIGHEST PER
CAPITA SPENDING ON STUDENTS IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD AND GUESS WHAT?
THERE ARE 13 PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOLS, NOT ONE CAT IS
PROFICIENT IN MATH, NOT ONE.
THE VEIL HAS NOT BEEN LIFTED.
SOCIALISM IS ON THE BALLOT,
SAFETY AND SECURITY IS ON THE
BALLOT AND CERTAINLY A
DILAPIDATED SCHOOL SYSTEM IS ON
THE BALLOT IN DONALD TRUMP’S
RECORD OF SUCCESS VERSUS BIDEN’S
RECORD OF FAILURE IN 50 YEARS IN
POLITICS, THAT’S ON THE BALLOT
IN 134 DAYS.
WHICH AMERICA DO YOU CHOOSE
BECAUSE THIS IS NOW THE BIGGEST
TOY SELECTION OF THE HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY.
I DON’T WANT TO BE DUE
HYPERBOLIC ON THIS, MAKE NO
MISTAKE.
SOCIALISM, ITS RADICALISM, IT IS
THE ONE PHILOSOPHY THAT HAS BEEN
TRIED, THE ONE INCARNATION AFTER
ANOTHER WORLDWIDE.
IT HAS FAILED AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
EVERY TIME THEY TRIED, NO MATTER
HOW THEY TRY TO SELL IT, IT ALL
ENDS UP IN FAILURE.
POWER FOR THE STATE AND THE
PEOPLE END UP IN POVERTY.
OTHERWISE, VENEZUELA WILL BE THE
RICHEST COUNTRY ON EARTH.
THAT IS WHAT IS AT STAKE FOR
THIS COUNTRY AND 134 DAYS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF THEY ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THEIR NEW DEAL, GET
RID OF OIL AND GAS AND MAKE
EVERYTHING FREE, FREE, FREE,
IT’S GOING TO FAIL, IT IS
MATHEMATICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACTUALLY DO WHAT THEY SAY
THEY’RE GOING TO DO.
WILL WE TRIUMPH OR WILL WE FAIL?
WE WILL FAIL AND AMERICA WILL
BECOME UNRECOGNIZABLE.
WELL, IN ABOUT 40 SOME ODD
THINGS, I HAVE IT ALL LAID OUT
MY BOOK.
"LIVE FREE OR DIE: AMERICA IN
THE WORLD ON THE BRINK" AND THAT
IS NOW, WELL COME OUT
AUGUST 4TH, BUT THAT IS ON THE
BALLOT IN 134 DAYS.
AMERICA IS AND HAS BEEN GREAT
FOR A REASON, NOT PERFECT,
GREAT.
IT’S BUILT ON PRINCIPLES,
FREEDOM, RUGGED INDIVIDUALISM.
SELF-SUFFICIENCY.
DEMOCRATS, THEY NOW WANT TO
FUNDAMENTALLY RIP OUT THOSE CORE
PRINCIPLES AND IT’S UP TO YOU,
THE PEOPLE.
I’M ONLY ONE LITTLE VOTE IN
NEW YORK.
I CAN’T VOTE MORE THAN ONCE.
I DO IT LEGALLY, I DO WITH THE
RIGHT WAY.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
SANCTUARY CITIES, SANCTUARY
STATES, IF YOU BELIEVE
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE FREE,
LOOK AT NEW YORK CITY, LOOK AT
NEW YORK STATE, LOOK AT
NEW JERSEY, CALIFORNIA AND TELL
ME YOU WANT THAT TO BE AMERICA
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT AMERICA WILL
BECOME.
OTHERWISE THIS COUNTRY WILL
NEVER BE THE SAME AGAIN, IS MY
PREDICTION.
THEY WIN, GUESS WHAT?
THIS COUNTRY WILL BE
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
IF THESE PLANS ARE IMPLEMENTED.